The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Number (2) --
(2.3).
It says if the code
[INAUDIBLE]
0 would be the [INAUDIBLE].
I thought it was, you're
generating
random values for that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you were but if
you look at what totes 0 is
collecting, so if you look at
the, where it draws a random
number, j is indexing
in totes, right?
So when j is 0 your standard
deviation, which is also being
indexed by j, is
going to be 0.
So you're always going to
get the same value.
Any more questions?
No?
OK, that was easy.
So in lecture we were talking a
lot about clustering, we've
been talking about clustering
the past, is it two lectures?
And we had two different
types of clustering
methods, what were they?
AUDIENCE: Hierarchical and--
PROFESSOR: Heirarchical
and K-means.
Can someone give me a run down
of what the steps are in
hierarchical clustering?
AUDIENCE: Something that breaks
everything down into
one cluster [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So let's say I have
a bunch of data points.
What would be the first step?
You're going to first assign
each point to a cluster.
So each point gets
its own cluster.
And then the next step
would be what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, so you're
going to find the two clusters
that are closest to each
other and merge them.
So in this very contrived
example, would be these guys.
And then you're going to keep
doing that until you get to a
certain number of
clusters, right?
So you merge these two, then you
might merge these two, and
you might merge these two, et
cetera, et cetera, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So you're going to
set the number of clusters
that you want at the outset, so
I guess, for the mammalian
teeth example, there was
stopping criteria of two
clusters, if I'm not mistaken.
So let's take a look at the code
here that implements a
hierarchical cluster.
So this is just some
infrastructure code, it builds
up the number of points.
We have a cluster set class,
which we'll go over in a
second, and then we just add,
for each point we're going to
create a cluster object, and
add it to the cluster set.
Let's take a look at
the cluster set.
Cluster set has one attribute,
the members attribute, and it
just has a set of points, or a
set of clusters, actually.
And the key method in here--
or the key methods are
merge-1 and merge-n.
Merge-n is what actually
implements
the clustering here.
So you give it the distance
metric that you're going to
use for your points, the number
of clusters that you
want at the end of your
clustering, the history
tracker, and then you also tell
it if you want to print
out some debugging
information.
So, which apparently is not used
to this method, oh, now
it is, merge-1.
Anyway, so while we have more
clusters than the number of
clusters we desire, we're going
to keep reiterating.
And on each step we're going
to call this function--
or method called merge-1
and just pass at
the distance metric.
And all merge-1 is going to
do is it's going to, if
there's only one--
if there's only one cluster
here, then it's just going to
return none.
If there are two clusters and
its going to merge them, and
if there are more than two
clusters, it's going to find
the closest, according to
the distance metric and
then merge those two.
So then the return value
is going to be the
two clusters it merged.
Let's look at the merge
clusters code.
All it does is it takes the
two clusters and for each
point, in both clusters, it adds
it to a new list points
and it creates a new cluster
from those points.
And then it removes two clusters
from members and adds
the newly created cluster.
So then, find closest method.
So what's this bit of
code doing here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, so we'll get
to the metric in a second.
So it initially finds, it looks
at the first two members
in the cluster set and it sets
minDistance to be that, and it
sets toMerge to be these
two members.
And then it narrates through
every possible pair of
clusters, in this cluster set
and finds the minimum distance
according to the metric.
So let's look at the
cluster class.
All the cluster object does
or class does is it
holds a set of points.
It knows the type of point that
it's holding because that
becomes important, when we talk
about the different types
of things that we want to
cluster, and then it also has
something called a centroid.
All a centroid is, is just the
middle of the cluster, if you
take all of the points and
average their distances, or
average their location.
So these different functions,
these just compute metrics
about this particular
cluster, right?
So single linkage dist., all
this is going to do is it
finds a minimum distance between
every pair of points
in the cluster.
And what does max linkage
distance do?
I'm sorry I'm mistaken it finds
the minimum distance
between this--
a point in this cluster
and a point in
another cluster, I misspoke.
So what does max linkage
distance do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The opposite.
I have to keep you talking
or you'll fall asleep.
And then, averageLinkageDist?
Same thing.
This is why having meaningful
function names is important,
because it helps you
explain code.
So it also has this method in
here called update and what
update does, is it takes a new
set of points and it sets the
points that this cluster has,
to be these new points.
And then it computes a new
centroid for this cluster.
And the return value is the
distance of the old centroid
from the new centroid.
And this becomes important in
some of the algorithms.
Then there's just some
bookkeeping stuff here, like
members will just give you all
the points in this cluster.
You all know what yield
does, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So yield returns a generator
object, which allows you to
iterate over elements.
So this was asked during
the quiz review.
What's the difference between
range and x range?
Right.
So if I have a range of values
it actually returns a
different type.
So I can print out
this list, right?
In this case, it will print out
the type of object it is,
so this is accomplished
using yield.
So if I wanted to write this
myself, what this is going to
do is going to return something
called a generator object.
And all it does is, instead of
holding all the numbers in
memory, it's going to return
them one at a time to me.
So like when I use range here,
it constructs a list and it
has all of those integers
in memory.
If I use xrange it's not going
to hold all the integers in
memory, but I can still
iterate over
them one at a time.
AUDIENCE: So within that
function [INAUDIBLE]
yield a bunch of times before
the function, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How is that
accomplished?
Does it operate [INAUDIBLE]
within the way you normally
have functions [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what this tells Python is
that when it sees a yield,
it's sort of like a return,
except it's telling Python
that I want to come back to this
location at some point.
So it a return just returns
out of the function
completely.
What a yield does is it takes
the value that is specified
after yield, and it returns to
the calling place in the
program that value.
But then, when it comes time
to get a new value, it'll
return back to where
this yield exited.
So kind of a way maybe
seeing this is if I
iterate over my xrange.
Each time it needs new value,
it's going to go back inside
this function and grab it.
So it looks like a function.
But what it's actually doing
is creating what's called a
generator object.
And it has these special
methods for
getting the next value.
So it's some nice
syntactic sugar.
But it's pretty neat.
But that's what's going on with
this yield statement here
is that instead of returning the
entire list of points, or
instead of doing it in some
other way, all it's doing is
just yielding each point one
at a time so that you can
iterate over them.
So what else?
So here's a method for computing
the centroid.
All we are going to do is total
up where each point is.
And then, take the average
over all the points.
Does that makes sense?
All right.
So the example we saw
was mammal teeth.
And the way that that's
accomplished in this set of
code is we're going to define a
sub-class of a class, point,
that's call mammal.
And what point does is it has a
name for a given data point.
It has a set of attributes.
And then, you can also give it
some normalized attributes.
If you don't give it the
normalized attributes, then
it'll just use the original
attributes.
So it becomes important
when we talk about--
when we do scaling over data,
which we'll do shortly.
So there's nothing really
special about it except for
this distance function.
It's just defining the Euclidean
distance for a given
multi-dimensional point.
So everyone knows that if
you have a point in two
dimensions, then if it's an
xy point, then it's just
x-squared plus y-squared
-- square root of.
It generalizes to higher
dimensions if you weren't
already aware.
So if I want to find the
straight line distance between
a point in 3D, it's just going
to be x-squared plus y-squared
plus z-squared --
square root.
That's all.
And then, so on and so forth.
So all this does is it
sub-classes point.
And it has this function,
scaleFeatures.
And what scaleFeatures does
is it'll take a key.
And in this case, we have to
find two ways of scaling this
data, of scaling this point.
So we have the identity, which
is it's just going to leave
every point alone.
And then, we have this 1 over
max, which is going to scale
each attribute by the maximum
value in this data set.
And if we look at the data
set, we know that our max
value is 6.
So you could do that
automatically.
But in this case, we're using
prior knowledge of the data
set that we have.
So why don't we do a cluster?
So this is going to do a
hierarchical cluster, right?
And what we're going to ask, if
I just specify the default
parameters, all it's going to
do is it's going to look for
two clusters.
It's going to use
the identity.
And it's just going to print
out the history, like when
it's performed the
different merges.
Unless I have extraneous code
that I'm already running.
So what starts off first is we
get a lot of merges with just
these single element
clusters, right?
So I have a beaver with a
groundhog, so I guess they're
pretty similar in
terms of teeth.
We have a squirrel with a
porcupine, wolf with a bear.
And so eventually, though, we
start finding clusters--
a wolf and a bear, I guess,
are more similar.
But they're also similar
with a dog.
So we're going to start merging
multi-point clusters.
So we start seeing to beaver and
groundhog cluster is going
to get merged with
the squirrel and
the porcupine cluster.
So if you were to visualize
this, the reason why it's
called hierarchical
clustering is--
which one did I say?
Beaver, groundhog--
these guys have been merged
into a cluster, right?
They started out as
their own cluster.
And they've been merged into
And then, the grey squirrel and
the porcupine, same thing.
They started off with their own
clusters at the beginning.
They got merged.
And now, what this step is
saying is that these two
clusters get merged.
So we're building this
tree, or hierarchy.
That's where the hierarchical
comes from.
So we use hierarchical
clustering a
lot in other fields.
So in speech recognition,
we can do a hierarchical
clustering of speech sounds.
So if I have say different
vowels, and maybe a couple of
consonants, I would expect to
see, say, these kind of
clustered together first.
And so what I might see is these
would be fricatives.
But then, I might have some
stops, like "t" and "b" that
get merged first.
So it's a way of making these
generalized groupings at
different levels.
I don't know.
Does anyone have any real
questions about hierarchical
clustering?
So should I move
on to k-means?
All right.
So what's the general
idea with k-means?
So I start off with a
set of data points.
What's my first step?
AUDIENCE: Choose your total
number of clusters?
PROFESSOR: Right, so I'm
going to choose a k.
So let's say for giggles we're
going to choose k equals 3.
And then, what's my next step?
AUDIENCE: Choose k's
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to pick k random points
from our data set.
All right, and then,
what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Cluster?
PROFESSOR: Then you'd cluster.
Yeah, all right.
So after we've chosen our three
centroids here, these
become our clusters, right?
And we're going to look
at each point.
And we're going to figure
out which cluster
they're closest to.
So in this case, this is going
to be a pretty easy
clustering.
So all these points are
going to belong here.
All these points are going
to belong here.
to belong here, right?
And then, we're going to update
our centroid for each
of these clusters.
And there's going to be a
distance that the centroid
moves each time we update it.
So in this case, the centroid
moved quite a bit, right?
Then, we're going to find the
maximum distance that the
centroid moved.
And if it's below a certain
cut off value, then we're
going to say, I've got a
good enough clustering.
If it's above a certain cut off
value, then what I'm going
to say is like, this centroid
moved quite a bit for this
cluster, right?
So I'm going to try
another iteration.
I'm going to say, for each one
of these points, I'm now going
to look and try to the closest
cluster that it belongs to
based on these new centroids.
And in this case, nothing's
really going to change.
So all of the deltas, all of
the centroids, are going to
stay the same.
So it's going to be below
the cut off value.
And it's going to stop.
So what's an advantage of
k-means over hierarchical
clustering?
AUDIENCE: More efficient?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let's say that I have
a million points.
If I were to hierarchically
cluster these, that means I'd
start off with a million
clusters.
And now, in each iteration,
I'm just going to
reduce it by 1.
I don't know, let's say 3, OK?
So on each iteration, we're just
reducing it by 1, which,
if that's all we were doing,
would not be so hard.
It doesn't take too long
to count down from a
million on a computer.
But on each one of these steps,
we have to compute the
pairwise distance between
each cluster.
So it's going to be n times n
minus 1 comparisons on each
step which, in this first case,
works out to a lot.
And it doesn't get
much better.
So approximately, right?
And it doesn't get much
better as we go down.
With k-means, what happens is
we just have to perform, on
each step, if we have a million
points and we have k
clusters, we just have to
perform k times 1 million
comparisons.
Because for each point, we
need to find the closest
centroid approximately.
So the upshot is that k-means
winds up being a lot more
efficient on each iteration,
which is why if you have a
large number of points, you
might want to choose k-means
over hierarchical clustering.
What's an advantage, though,
of hierarchical clustering
over k-means?
Even though it's less efficient,
what's another--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: More thorough.
PROFESSOR: More thorough.
AUDIENCE: And you can get a lot
of different levels that
you can look at.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can get
a lot of different levels.
So you can look at the
clusterings from different
perspectives.
But the key thing with--
AUDIENCE: You don't necessarily
know how many
clusters there actually are.
Hierarchical clustering will
tell you all of the
[INAUDIBLE].
You can just go down
the tree and--
PROFESSOR: Right, so you could
go down different levels of
the tree and pick however many
number of clusters you want.
But the big reason--
or one of the kind of main
advantages that hierarchical
clustering has over k-means
is that k-means is random.
It's non-deterministic.
Hierarchical clustering
is deterministic.
It's always going to give
you the same result.
With k-means, because your
initial starting conditions
are random because you're
choosing k random points, the
end result will be different
each time.
And so when we do k-means
clustering, this necessarily
means that we don't necessarily
want to do it once.
Like if we choose k equals 3,
we might want to do five
different k-means clusterings
and take the best one.
So that's one of the big
points with k-means.
There's a degenerate condition
with k-means.
So if my objective is to--
if my stopping criteria is
that the centroid doesn't
move, what's a really easy way
to make the centroid not move
by choosing k?
What was it?
K equals n, right?
So if I have n points and I have
k equals n, then all of
my points are going to
be their own cluster.
And every time I update,
I'm never
going to move my centroid.
So in your problem set, you're
going to be asked to compute a
standard error for each of the
clusters and a total error for
the entire cluster.
So what that is, is if I have
the centroids, and I had each
point in the centroids--
so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the centroid for
each cluster.
And I'm going to find the
distance from each point in
the cluster to the centroid.
And then, I'm going to sum up
all of those distances over
the entire cluster.
That's going to give
me my error.
Not sure if this equation's
totally right.
There might be a like of
division in there.
But the general idea, what I'm
trying to emphasize, is that
we can reduce this number
by just increasing
the number of k.
And if we make k equal n, then
this is going to be 0.
So like I was saying with
statistics, you never want to
trust just one number.
With k-means, you never just
want to trust one clustering
or one measurement of error.
You want to look at it from
multiple perspectives and
advantage points.
So why don't we look at the code
and try to match up all
of that stuff with what you'll
see on your problem set?
So the big function to
look at for k-means
is aptly named k-means.
And it's going to take
a set of points.
It's going to take a
number of clusters.
It's going to take a cut off
value, and a point type, and a
variable named maxIters.
So first step, we get our
initial centroids.
All we're going to do is we're
going to sample our points
randomly and choose k of them.
Our clusters, we're going
to represent as a list.
And we are going to, for all
the points in the initial
centroids, we are going
to add a cluster
with just that point.
And then, we get into
our loop here.
So what this is saying is, while
our biggest change in
centroid is greater than the
cut off and we haven't
exceeded the number of
iterations, or the maximum
number of iterations, we're
going to keep trying to refine
our cluster.
So that brings up a point I
actually failed to mention.
Why should we have this cut
off point, maxiters?
AUDIENCE: It'll go forever?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's a
chance that, if our cut-off
value is too small, or we have a
point that's on a border and
likes to jump between clusters
and move the centroid just
above the cut off point,
that we'll never
converge to our cut off.
And so we want to set up
a secondary break.
So we have this maxIters,
which defaults to 100.
So with this set up, though,
there's a couple of things you
have to consider.
And this is, one, you need
to make sure that
maxiters is not too small.
Because if it's too small,
you're not going to converge.
And you don't want to make it
too large, because then your
algorithm will just take
forever to run, right?
Likewise, you don't want
to make your cut
off too small, either.
So sometimes you have to play
around with the algorithm to
figure out what the best
parameters are.
And that's, oftentimes, more of
an art than a hard science.
So anyway, continuing on.
for each iteration, we're
going to set up
a new set of clusters.
And we're going to set them
initially to have
no points in them.
And then, for all the points in
our data set, we are going
to look for the smallest
distance.
So that means we are
going to look--
we're going to initially set
our smallest distance to be
the distance from the point
to the first centroid.
And then, we're just going to
interate through all the
centroids, or through all the
clusters, and then find the
smallest distance.
Is anyone lost by that?
Make sense?
Once we find that, we're just
going to add that point to the
new clusters.
And then, we're going to
go through our update.
We're going to iterate through
each of our clusters.
We are going to update the
points in the cluster.
So remember, the update method
sets the points of the cluster
to be this new set of points
you've given it.
And it also updates the
centroid, or it updates the
centroid, and it returns the
delta between the old centroid
and the new centroid.
So that's where this change
variable is coming from.
And then, we're just go look for
the biggest change, right?
And if, at some point in our
clustering, the centroids have
stabilized and our clusters
are relatively stationary,
then our max change
will be small.
And it'll wind up terminating
the algorithm.
And all this function does is,
once it's converged or it's
gone through the maximum number
of iterations, it's
just going to find the
maximum distance of a
point to its centroid.
So it's going to look for a
point that has a maximum
distance from its corresponding
centroid.
And that's going to be the
coherence of this clustering.
And then, it's just going to
return a tuple containing the
clusters and the maximum
distance.
So it's not a hard algorithm
to understand.
And it's pretty simple
to implement.
There any real questions about
what's going on here?
So the example that he went over
in lecture with k-means
was this counties clustering
example.
So we had a bunch of data of
different counties in the US.
And we just played around with
clustering them and seeing
what we got.
So if we made five clusters,
and we clustered on all the
features, wanted to see what the
distribution would be for,
say, incomes, what this
function, test, is going to do
is it's going to take
a k, a cut off,
and a number of trials.
So remember, we said that
because k-means is
non-deterministic, we're going
to want to run it a number of
times to find maybe we get a bad
initial set of points for
our centroids or for
our clusters.
And that gives us a
bad clustering.
So we're going to run it a
number of times and try and
prevent that from happening.
AUDIENCE: How do we [INAUDIBLE]
multiple runs,
because [INAUDIBLE]
really different clustering
happens [INAUDIBLE]
after you run it a
couple of times?
PROFESSOR: It can be tricky,
to be honest.
One technique you could use
would be to have a training
set and a development set.
What I mean by that is, you
perform a clustering on the
training set.
And then, you take the
development set, and you
figure out which clusters
they belong to.
And then, you measure the error
of that development set.
So once you've assigned these
development points to the
clusters, you measure the
distance to the centroid.
And you sum up the squared
distances, and you sum up over
all the clusters.
Then if you do that a number of
times, what you would do is
you'd choose the clustering
that gave you the smallest
error on your development set.
And then, you'd say, that's
probably my best clustering
for this data.
So that's one way of doing it.
There's multiple ways
of skinning the cat.
Was trying to think of
a good aphorism.
And actually, that's what's
on your problem set.
One of the problems on your
problem set is to cluster
based on a holdout set and see
what the effect of the error
is on this holdout set.
So did that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then, choosing k, there's
different methods
for doing it, too.
A lot of it is you run a lot
of experiments and you see
what you get.
This is where the research part
comes in for a lot of
applications.
So you can also try some other
automatic methods, like
entropy or other,
more complicated
measurements of error.
But don't worry about those.
For our purposes, if you get
below the cut off value, and
you run a number of iterations,
and you've
minimized your error on your
test set, we'll be happy.
We want you to be familiar with
k-means, but not experts
in it because it's a useful
tool for your kit.
Anyway, so all this code is
going to do is it's going to
run a number of trials.
It's going to perform
k-means clustering.
And it's going to look for the
clustering with the smallest
maximum distance.
So remember, the return value
of k-means is the maximum
distance from a point
to its centroid.
We're going to define our best
clustering as being the
clustering that gives us the
smallest max distance.
So that's another way you
would choose your best
clustering.
Yeah, and that's all we're
going to do for
this bit of code here.
We're going to find the average
income in each cluster
and draw a histogram.
So I think this is
actually done.
So we have five clusters.
And what they're showing us
is that the clusters--
if we take the average income
of the different clusters,
they're going to be centered
at these average incomes.
Let's see what some other
plots look like.
This set of examples is
using a point type
that's called county.
And county, like the mammal
class, inherits from point.
And it defines a set of
features that can be
used, or a set of--
it calls them filters.
But basically, if you pass it
one of these filter names,
like allEducation,
noEducational, wealthOnly,
noWealth, what this is doing
is it's selecting
this tuple of tuples.
And so if I say wealthonly, it's
going to use this tuple
as a filter.
And for each element in this
tuple of tuples, it has a
tuple that has the name of the
attribute and whether or not
it should be used in
the clustering.
So if it has a 1, it
should be used.
If it has a 0, it shouldn't
be used.
So if we look at how that's
applied, it'll get a
filterSpec.
And then, it'll just set an
attribute called atrFilter.
And if we see where that's
used, then it's going to
iterate through all
of the attributes.
And if the given attribute has
a 1, then it's going to
include it in the set of
features that are used in this
distance computation.
So did that make sense at all?
No?
All right.
So the idea is to illustrate
that if you use different
features when you're doing
your clustering, you'll
probably attain different
clusterings.
So in that first example
I showed, we
used all the features.
But in this example, we are
going to look at only wealth.
And that includes the features,
if we look at this
set of filters here, it's going
to include the home
value, the income,
the poverty.
And then, all the other
attributes, like population
change, it's not include.
So those aren't going to be
used in the clusterings.
So this is going to change what
our clusters look like.
So if we look at what we have
for our clusters-- well,
that's not very clear.
Yeah, so let's see
what happens.
I'm not sure that's really
going to show us.
Probably better if I show
them all at once, right?
So this will take a while.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Actually I had just
one question [INAUDIBLE]
but there is a method showing
us [INAUDIBLE] iterative
additionally?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's like iterValues
or iterKeys, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
to go about using that in
actual code.
PROFESSOR: In actual code?
So you know that if you
have a dictionary, d,
you can do like d.keys.
So remember I was demo-ing
that code, the difference
between range and xrange?
Same thing.
This is going to return
an actual list of
all the keys, right?
What's d.iterkeys returns is a
generator object that gives
you, one by one by one, each
key in the dictionary.
So a lot of times, you guys in
your code will use something
like for k in d.keys(): to
iterate through all the keys
in the dictionary.
What this method does, though,
is it creates an actual copy
of that list of keys, right?
So when you call d.keys, if you
have a lot of keys in your
dictionary, it's going to go
one by one by one by one
through each of those keys,
add it to a list, and then
return it to you.
What d.iterkeys does is it skips
that going one by one by
one and adding it
to a new list.
It just gives you a generator
object which, when you use it
in a for loop--
when you use it in a for loop,
it's going to just yield the
key one at a time without
creating a separate list.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: So will it
be more efficient?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's generally
more efficient.
And then, there's also, I think,
iterValues, which goes
through each of the values.
And then, I think there's
iterItems.
And I think, if I'm not
mistaken, if you do something
just like that, so you do, for
k, v in d, this is going to
iterate through a tuple that
contains the key and the
values associated
with that key.
And it's equivalent
to doing this.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So where
were we here?
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have
done this all at once.
Why don't we just look at two?
Why don't we take a look at what
the average incomes, what
the clustering gives us for
average incomes for education
versus no education.
That's probably not going to
be a very good comparison.
Just doing five trials and two
trials for each clustering.
So k-means is the efficient
one, which means that
hierarchical would take
a long, long time.
There we go.
So these are the average incomes
if we cluster with k
equals 50 on education.
And then, there should
be another one.
I didn't create the
new figure.
So apparently there's
a bug in the code.
I wanted to show the two plots
side by side so you could see
the differences.
Because what you
should see is--
we would see a different
distribution in incomes among
the clusters if we clustered
based on no education versus
education level.
But my code is buggy and
not working the way
I expected it to.
So I apologize.